So Charles and Michael just gave
you some of the general theory and
inspiration behind machine learning.
They also covered the three types of
machine learning that will make up a lot
of your work in this Nanodegree
program supervised, unsupervised, and
reinforcement learning.
Now let's cover some of the examples
of the applications of machine learning
a little bit more detail.
Like Sebastian self driving car or
health care or trading.
We've taken a few videos from some
other courses we've produced so
you can get an idea for
what machine learning can do.
Notice, especially how in every
case we can describe the problem
as learning concepts from raw data.
Learning concepts and building models
is the core of machine learning.
And every problem you tackle can
be described in these terms.